this is the one thing i wanted to get to
so you know my favorite feature the
other thing is i have a solution for
apple
which i have been bringing up year after
year
i bought the goddamn phone it's my
device it is no longer yours and you're
making
they're charging 12 i think i paid 1200
for my last one
and i i read the cost of 350 or
something maybe like
basically you could buy a car for the
cost of
15 iphones the latest one it's a really
expensive high margin product
in your settings there should be a
button you clicked
that says allow third-party apps
and app stores this would be the perfect
way for them to say we are not going to
give you customer support
if you click this button here's a
warning your phone now is your
responsibility if you get
hacked if it breaks you
no don't come to the genius bar you're
on your own
just like you know and and then we'd be
done with this whole debate
and people could just load the amazon
app store whatever they want what do you
think of my solution is this
one i don't know if it's viable from
their perspective but
if we were if you and i were going to
lobby you know congress the eu etc which
we could do you and i
and david and a couple of people could
write a blog post
let us do what we want with our phone
and we'll assume the risk
yeah i just want choice i want choice
too that's it like i want choice and
here's the other thing
to your point i almost wonder maybe this
is a cynical
person in me you know mostly now they
don't really let they don't really
encourage people to buy phones now now
they're just rented right you just kind
of pay this monthly yeah
so it's not really yours oh yeah so you
have to kind of implement
this idea of yeah paying outright it's
like this is mine now
right i should have a little bit of
control over like what gets on it and
it's up to me it's my thing it's my
device it's my choice and if a company
like that i trust wants to send me ios
software that way
they should be able to of course of
course and i understand like i really i
understand the fundamental principles of
the app store as it
as it was in its purest form way back
when loading software onto mobile phones
back in 2007
or six sucked horribly it was a terrible
terrible thing i remember having to do
this with like loader apps and like you
know what at a palm pre or whatever i
had before it's a horrible experience so
apple really truly innovated as apple
does and they're wonderful at this and
they're wonderful breaking categories
and
they're amazing their user experience is
fantastic but things have changed
yeah and as a you know as a customer
like let me if i want
trust the companies that i want to trust
why should apple be the arbiter of who i
can trust remember that
you use vlc the open source video player
so you couldn't have a video player
you were also not allowed to have a
browser so you couldn't download
opera or whatever browser dolphin you
wanted and the public pressure
from entrepreneurs and from users i
think pushed
apple to realize you know what if we
squeeze too hard
you know like princess leia i told darth
vader like
the more galaxies are going to slip
through your fingers